in the last video and even and odd
functions I talked about how you
shouldn't get confused between even
functions and even numbers and odd
functions and odd numbers and I said
there wasn't any obvious connection
between the word even function and the
our notion of even numbers or any
connection between odd functions and odd
numbers and I was wrong there actually
is a relatively obvious connection this
was pointed out by the YouTube user know
theists and the connection and it almost
I almost kind of explicitly did it in
the last example when I showed it an
even function I showed you x squared
when I showed you an odd function I
showed you X to the third power when I
wanted to show you another odd function
I showed you Y is equal to X or f of X
is equal to X to the first power and so
you might start to notice what no
theists pointed out is that kind of
these these archetypical or I guess you
know these good examples or these simple
examples of even and odd functions when
I'm just when I just have a very simple
X raised to some power the whether the
power is even or odd does describe or
it's it's it's going to tell you whether
the function is even or odd and you want
to be very careful here not all not all
even or odd functions even have
exponents in them they could be
trigonometric functions there might be
other some other type of wacky functions
you don't have to have exponents it's
just that these exponents are probably
where the motivations for calling these
even functions and odd functions came
from and let me just be clear it's not
just also any polynomial and even in the
last video when we had X to the third
plus one this was neither even or odd
but if you just have the pure X raised
to some power then all of a sudden it
because the the notions of even and odd
seem to or I get some motivations for
calling even and odd so you start to
make sense because if I have f of X is
equal to X to the first power that's the
same thing as Y is equal to X this is
odd and that and it kind of gels with
the name because we are also raising it
to an odd power if we have f of X is
equal to x squared we saw in the
previous video this is
even and it kind of gels with the idea
that we're raising it to an even power I
could keep going if it was to the X 2/3
that is odd
I could keep going if we're raising it
to any if we just have let me write it
this way in general if you have f of X
is equal to X to the N then this is odd
odd function if n is odd is an odd
number and this is an even function even
function if n is even and I want to make
it very clear here those whole the whole
point of this video is just to clarify
the motivation for calling them even or
odd functions not all even functions are
going to be of of this form here where
it's X raised to some even power and not
all odd functions are going to be and I
also don't want you to be confused that
if I have something like X to the third
and then I have other stuff Oh
past that you say oh X to the third
that's an odd number but this is not an
odd function just when it's just kind of
a pure down a pure stripped down X to
the third or X to the first can you
really make that statement but that
really is probably where the motivation
comes for naming them even or odd
functions and then the other symmetric
functions even if they even if they
don't let's say the other even functions
even if they don't involve an exponent
maybe this is some type of trigonometric
function it's kind of you're calling it
even because you're saying well it's
kind of like it has the same type of
symmetry as a as a as say x squared or x
to an even power so you kind of group
them all together as even functions and
then all of these even though this may
or may not have an exponent in it it has
the same type of symmetries as X raised
to an odd power so that's why we call
them odd functions well thank you know
theist
for that that that that pointing that
out